joining us now with more house oversight
committee chairman James Comer is with
us sir how are you
well I would
I would have the purview of the house
government reform and oversight
committee to look into okay how did the
cocaine get there what about the two
previous instances of drugs in the white
house and I ask you uh Congressman what
if it was Anthrax what if it was
fentanyl there have been police officers
law enforcement that have just touched
uh bags and Contraband with fentanyl in
it ingested somehow some of that dust
and they need Narcan five minutes later
so how dangerous is that in a building
where the president is
it's very dangerous it's very disturbing
one of two things has happened here
either number one the Secret Service is
lying to us and they're covering for
someone or number two they're
incompetent because this is supposed to
be the most secure dwelling in America
and for the Secret Service to admit to
the world that not only can they not
figure out who dropped off a white
powdery substance in one of three
locations in the White House that
remember that story's changed three
times where the cocaine was actually
found but also that there have been two
other instances where illegal drugs were
found on the premise in the White House
this is unacceptable we spend a lot of
money a lot of tax dollars to make sure
that we have the best Secret Service
that money can buy but yet they can't
determine who brings illegal substances
into the White House I think that's
that's very disturbing Congressman I'm
equally as to disturb that they gave up
after 10 days of investigating and
announced on day 11. we're done we
didn't we're not going to find the
person responsible that to me is the
height of irresponsibility uh I would
like answers from the Secret Service why
they gave up so quickly
that's a great question you know they
spent 11 days to try to figure out who
left an illegal substance in the white
house but they've been spending over
five years investigating the bidens for
all their money laundering all their
racketeering all their tax evasion and
according to U.S attorney whites they're
still investigating uh the the president
and his son for bribery and for
potential wrongdoing so it makes no
sense you know the Secret Service hadn't
really received a black eye like the
Department of Justice or the FBI but
unfortunately today this is another name
on the list of agencies that have run
amok again either they're not being
truthful with the house oversight
committee or they're incompetent by not
being able to determine who left this
substance it's hard for me to believe
that our technology at the FBI couldn't
Identify some DNA on this bag of cocaine
well have they had not been politicized
I might have confidence in them telling
us the truth you have made a a lot of
progress in your investigation into the
Biden family and the farm business
dealings of the Biden family you have a
very important hearing next Wednesday
why is that hearing going to be
different I understand that we might be
hearing a lot of new information
yeah we've been sitting down some new
bank records uh obviously it's very
encouraging to read the transcript that
the ways and committees had with the
transcribe interview with the two Irish
whistleblowers because they actually
knew a lot about many of these shell
companies and I think they were on the
right track until they were told to
stand down so the American people are
going to get to watch live both
whistleblowers including whistleblower X
who's never revealed his identity he
will do that the day of our hearing and
everyone can see hopefully Fox will be
covering that Sean and we have specific
substantive questions about many of
these wires about many of these shell
companies about potential money
laundering about potential racketeering
and I believe that these two witnesses
are going to be able to answer those
questions so many times Sean you have
these Congressional hearings and you
know they're all they're all hat no
cattle you don't really learn anything
new and they're not substantive this
should be a very substantive informative
hearing for the American people and this
is going to be the first time the
American people actually hear
credible Witnesses say under oath
exactly what crimes have been committed
by the Biden family do you have standing
to go before the judge they they have
this plea deal no jail time for Hunter
um do you have standing to go to this
judge and request that that steal not be
not be agreed to by the judge because of
new information and new evidence has
been forthcoming
we have to go through the Department of
Justice unfortunately for things like
granting immunity and and yeah right no
long story short all right let me ask
you this when when we got these WhatsApp
messages I'm sitting here with my father
we would like to understand why the why
the committed
um uh the commitment has not been
fulfilled uh tell the director we'd like
to resolve it now before it gets out of
hand and now means tonight and Z if I
get a call or a text from anyone
involved in this other than using or the
chairman I will make certain that the
that between the man sitting next to me
his father Joe and every person he knows
and my ability to forever hold the
grudge that you will regret not
following my direction I'm sitting here
waiting for the call with my father okay
Joe Biden he's implicated his father
again he's been implicated this on many
times my question to you is simple
that's that's that to me sounds like a
Shakedown Mr chairman and that to me
sounds like Joe Biden full involvement
and one week less than a week after that
exchange didn't the Biden family get
five million dollars transferred to them
from that Energy company in China
yes and remember that Energy company is
the same Energy company that was paying
guy Luft and the Department of Justice
indicted gal Luft on being an
unretchered foreign agent yet Hunter
Biden received about 25 times more money
from that same Chinese Energy company
and they let him walk free so we're in
addition to having the Committee hearing
with the Irish whistleblowers where
we're going to be able to ask very
substantive tax questions we're also
going to be having depositions and
transcribed interviews where we can ask
people exactly what Joe Biden knew and
when he knew it so I think next week has
the potential to be a very uh in very
productive week with respect to our
investigation and I think it's going to
be there will be a lot of questions that
Joe Biden's going to have to answer and
I don't know how much longer the
mainstream media can turn a blind eye to
this because the evidence is
overwhelming that many crimes were
committed and Avi obviously Joe Biden
had to be front and center in this
chairman Comer thank you as always we
appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else